let's do a lightning round if you were
elected president name some of the
people that you expect or you would like
to appoint as Secretary of State who do
you who for you would be a great
secretary of state of mind
uh I don't know about that I you know I
don't think I can answer that question
because
I
um
I don't really want to Telegraph my
choices like that I mean you know I love
uh I love Tulsi gabbard I like her that
you know she understands a you know the
importance of
um I've I've I've
disentangling of unraveling the Empire
and unraveling the war machine would you
ban gas stoves uh in this a lightning
round we'll come back to these in depth
if you would like you know people are
talking about banning Subs the Biden
Administration is about talking about
banning gas stoves yes or no
I would not add gas stoves great uh
would you ban the use of Roundup
herbicide
uh
would I ban it I would
certainly make them uh label it and I
would yeah everything I could could to
make sure that Monsanto is honest about
the injuries that it causes that people
are buying Now with an open
you know and with an army arm's life
negotiation understanding that they're
buying something that's deadly poisonous
okay uh would you ban would you ban any
would you ban any major prescription or
over-the-counter drugs that are now on
the market
uh
I I None comes to mind at the moment but
you know would you uh you uh have a
personal history of of substance abuse
your family has uh you know certain
recurring motifs along that would you
legalize drugs or or what currently
illegal drugs would you legalize
I would I would decriminalize marijuana
on a federal basis and allow the states
to regulate it
I would have a federal tax on it though
and I would
apply that tax to uh building
rehabilitation centers around the
country and providing people you know
drug rehabilitation uh what about
psychedelics which have been uh
decriminalized at the state level in
Oregon and Colorado definitely
decriminalize Alex okay uh would you
support immigration reforms that make it
easier for more people to come here and
live and work legally in America yes I
would okay uh would make it impossible
for people to
across the border illegally and I would
open up immigration for legal
immigration
would you ban uh so-called assault
weapons
well I'm not going to take away
anybody's guns
hey do if
if there wasn't consensus where
Republicans and Democrats voted a
majority to do that I would sign the
bill
great uh would you pardon Ross Albrecht
the founder of the Silk Road the Deep
Web drug Market Julian Assange of
WikiLeaks or Edward Snowden
I would pardon us on
immediately because he's a newspaper
publisher and it is crazy uh it's crazy
what they're trying to do to him it's
completely any American I would Pop I
would pardon Snowden because
what Snowden did for the American people
was to you know help restore at least
some semblance of democracy and the
importance of the of them
information he released
was so it's so it's a tested to the fact
that Congress passed legislation uh
recognizing you know the disclosures
that he had and making sure that you
know to try to make sure that those kind
of abuses didn't occur again so I think
he is a hero not uh it shouldn't be
treated as a villain
um with Ross Albrecht I I you know I
need to
I need to look into that my my
understanding of foreign
uh you know was given two life terms
for something that normally you would
not be given that and if I investigate
this which I'm going to do very very
quickly
and I find out that he was not being
punished so much for his crimes but
being punished as an example to teach a
lesson or to uh you know to
uh to increase the bias against uh
against you know Bitcoin and I I will
release him reasons audiences is largely
made up of Libertarians we believe in
free minds and free markets in limiting
government and increasing individual
autonomy as you're running for president
and you're you're pulling you know 15 18
in various polls what is a message to
Libertarians who believe in you know
free minds and free markets that you can
bring to them
well I think I've always been aligned
with Libertarians on
on most issues I mean there's tweaks
that I have
um you know the as an environmentalist I
don't think uh I don't think
libertarianism works well in the Commons
at least in any way that's practical
but I but when it you know and those are
those are
policy those are assets that are not
susceptible to private property
ownership like the shared assets of our
community what we call the public trust
assets or the the common so the
Commonwealth
uh the air the water the wildlife
Fisheries public lands uh aquifers those
kind of things that you do need
government regulation
um because
of a an economic law called tragedy of
the commons which which which
suggests that all of us will catch the
last fish in the ocean but doesn't that
also imply that we should be privatizing
more of the commons because when you
have clear property rights you tend to
take better care of them than if they're
left to the public
I you know I've seen schemes like that
you know particularly regulation of
Fisheries that have work well in some
cases but
there's something really undemocratic
about it I mean what you know one of the
reasons that we've that British you know
rose up and fought the Battle of running
meat was because King John tried to
privatize the you know the rivers of
England the Thames and erect tolls and
the Thames
he privatized uh you know the game
animals the fish and the hair which is
what a problem with Robin Hood he
privatized the fisheries and those
those assets were a social safety net so
if you're a farmer and you're corrupt
and come in and you could go down to the
Thames and you could pull out a fish and
you could feed your family even go into
the forest
and kill a deer and I and you know
there's something very Democratic in
fact the magnet the full uh name of the
bad part is that card a charter of the
forest
uh because it it recognized that the
commons belonged to all of us that
whether you're rich or poor humble or
Noble
Acura white European or you know African
or wherever your real Origins if you
were a citizen
you had an equal right to cross over a
beach and pull out your fish that was an
excerpt from the reason interview with
Robert F Kennedy Jr who's running for
president if you want to see another
excerpt go here if you want to see the
full thing and you should go here
come back next Thursday at 1 pm eastern
time when Zach Weigel and I will be
talking to somebody that you absolutely
want to hear from